[Music]
hi I'm Robert Kubus and I'd like to
introduce you to Google cloud spanner a
fully managed relational database
service cloud spend our functions just
like a traditional database except that
it's horizontal scalable we're still
providing asset transactions and SQL
semantics and we don't give any
performance up for that now this is
important because if you have ever
deployed a global multi-regional
database you know that there are certain
steps from configuring machines setting
up replication and failover and design
your charting and keeping all of that
running can be a challenge too while you
may not encounter all these challenges
today knowing that you don't have to
worry about them while you cross vary
scalability boundaries in the future
we'll give you a great deal of peace of
mind to give you a picture of just how
amazing cloud spanner is let me start by
showing you how easy it is to get
started with cloud spanner we turn all
that chaos that I just talked about into
one screen you just name the instance
true single or multi region we pick your
rest here and how many nodes you want I
pick 42 because that is always the right
answer we click create and in seconds we
have a distributed database at our
disposal but let's talk about a more
practical example imagine your ticket
seller selling tickets to events
worldwide it's pretty important that you
only sell each ticket once that buyers
experience a high-performance website
and that everyone to use the same ticket
and renter e for this example we have
deployed cloud spanner in three Google
regions US Europe and Asia all connected
by our really high-performance private
global network we are running workloads
that emulate customers buying billions
of tickets for 1 million events here's
the schema of our application you see
tables with columns that can be joined
together just like in any other
relational database there are
significant of numbers of rows for some
of those tables so this is a really
large relational database in our demo
app each purchase transaction involves
the complex mix of reads of multiple
rows from and writes to many of these
tables we are checking the availability
of tickets fetching account information
and update ticket owners and counters
you can even run SQL queries against
this database while handling all that
load in the Google cloud developer
console you can find the query entry
under your database in our case here we
are looking at a query that checks the
availability of tickets on May 12th at 7
p.m. in Germany all this out blocking
those critical by transaction that are
happening all around the world what's
important here is what you don't see and
how unremarkable this SQL looks like
there's no additional complexity in the
query form a charting system there is no
need to join across multiple shards of
your database or anything alike
responder you can just simply underst
your SQL skills and put them to work
again on a massive scale able or so
until a distributed database and to help
you optimize degrees you have the
possibility to inspect the query plan
before or after running your career
right in the developer console now real
world applications and workloads change
over time and your database needs to
adjust while your business keeps running
cloudspinner lets you make transactional
consistency I updates with no downtime
at all you can simply add or change
columns while your workload is running
and what happens is your app grows and
you need to add capacity with
traditional systems you have to figure
out how to scale up get an even more
powerful server and upgrade the hardware
or you can try to scale out but that
involves a lot of complexity middleware
and educational risk and takes time in
large banner I go to the developer
console edit my instance add more nodes
and click Save
that's it that's the power of a fully
managed horizontally scalable SQL
database and of course since we designed
spanner at Google to scale with our
business we made sure it can handle very
large databases let's switch over to our
monitoring tools Tech driver the graphs
show the history of our demo database
and there are a couple of things to
point out here first in the upper right
you'll see that when we setup the
database we were able to load data at
over 800 megabytes per second
sustainable that even peaked at around
one gigabyte per second that's just
crazy fast right second you can see on
the lower left we run the whole demo
against the database that is over 80
terabyte
illogical data let's recap you can
create a highly reliable performant
fully managed multi-regional database in
seconds cloud spanner is a relational
database with the power of SQL and asset
transactions plus advanced features like
versioning strong consistency and online
schema changes you can scale out and in
as needed fully managed and you don't
have to worry about replication your
system even automatically Tunes itself
for performance and last but not least
cloud spanner is built for scale Google
has been running largest operational
data set on it globally for years check
out cloud spanner today and find more
information like best practices and case
studies of spanner on cloud.google.com
slash spanner
[Music]